today a new study warned that humans
could be responsible for bringing about
the sixth mass extinction a marine life
now the study authors looked at the five
previous times that there's been a mass
extinction and they compared it to
what's taking place in the oceans today
and they found that the bigger the
animals are the greater their risk of
extinction so around 250 million years
ago the end permian mass extinction
wiped out around ninety five percent of
marine life but species size wasn't a
big factor in whether or not they were
likely to survive it also wasn't a big
factor during the n cretaceous period
which happened 65 million years ago and
that killed off the dinosaurs but the
author's studied 2497 ancient and modern
marine species and they found that over
the past 65 million years size has
become the biggest factor in how likely
a marine mammal is becoming extinct now
let's have a look in a bit more detail
here because if you look at forty
percent of marine species longer than a
metre are endangered that's like the
great white sharks for example and it
increases to eighty-six percent if the
mammal is over ten meters long and the
blue whale which is the largest sea
mammal has seen as much as a ninety
percent reduction in its population now
by comparison the bioluminescent bristle
mouth which measure just three inches
across they have a population of
hundreds of trillions scientists say
that this is a pattern that's been seen
before so on land for example the
extinction of big mammals like the
mammoth and also the giant ground sloth
over the past sixty six million years is
also thought to have been caused by
human hunting so big animals big chance
a big risk of extinction